das was ein niederländisches
forschungsteam jetzt herausgefunden hat
widerspricht wirklich allen regeln der
physik und das hat zur folge dass unsere
globalen klimamodelle grundlegend
überarbeitet werden müssen
konkret geht es um gigantische
staubpartikeln sie sehr weite strecken
zurücklegen die fachleute stehen vor
einem riesigen rätsel
ihre beobachtungen basieren wohlauf
prozessen gehen der atmosphäre die uns
noch gänzlich unbekannt sind alles was
er zu diesem mysteriösen staub phänomen
wissen müssen jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann und nur dann verpasst er
nicht herzlich willkommen
für klimaforscherin und klimaforscher
ist die größe der partikel in unsere
atmosphäre von entscheidender bedeutung
denn die fachleute gehen bei ihren
modellen davon aus dass partikel erst ab
einem gewissen durchmesser einfluss auf
das klima unserer erde nehmen denn die
partikelgröße entscheidet maßgeblich
darüber wie weit diese beispielsweise
durch winde transportiert werden können
in diesem kontext neben forschungsteams
weltweit an dass lediglich partikel die
kleiner als zehn mikrometer sind
überhaupt folgen für die
klimabedingungen haben könnten
ein teilchen durchmesser ab etwa 20
mikrometer dagegen sei zu groß für deren
transport in der luft über lange
strecken
auf grundlage dieser annahme werden
partikel mit einem größeren durchmesser
derzeit nicht in die aktuellen
klimamodelle und berechnung mit
einbezogen ein irrtum der weit reiche
folgen haben könnte wie sich jetzt
herausstellte ein niederländisches
forschungsteam nämlich stieß bei
untersuchung auf verhältnismäßig große
staubpartikel die mithilfe von winden
eine äußerst lange strecke von 3500
kilometern zurückgelegt haben müssen
konkret handelt es sich dabei um
teilchen die die fachleute unter anderem
von bojen aus dem atlantischen ozean
im zeitraum zwischen 2013 und 2016
entnommen hatten sie haben den analysen
zufolge tatsächlich den etwa dreieinhalb
tausend kilometer langen weg aus der
sahara wüste dorthin zurück gelegt in
diesen proben enthalten waren wirklich
gigantisch große partikel mit einer
größe von 400 50 mikrometern dazu james
harrison der in der studie beteiligt war
die bislang bekannten prinzipien
schließen eigentlich aus dass solch
massive teilchen in der atmosphäre so
weit transportiert werden können das
lässt uns also vermuten dass ist einen
bisher unbekannten atmosphären prozess
oder eine kombination mehrerer prozesse
gibt die sie in der luft halten
zu klären ist also jetzt durch welche
kräfte und bewegungen in der atmosphäre
dazu fähig sind auch partikel einer
solchen größe solch lange strecken zu
transportieren physikalisch gesehen ist
das ein riesiges rätsel dazu michelle
van dadurch die auch an der studie
beteiligt war die tatsache dass größere
staubpartikel für solch eine lange zeit
in der atmosphäre schweben steht im
widerspruch zu den physikalischen
gesetzen der schwerkraft ein ergebnis
das bedeutende folgen für die
klimaforschung haben könnte denn klar
ist partikel in der luft haben großen
einfluss auf die bildung von wolken und
nicht nur das laut dem niederländischen
forschungsteam sind partikel mit einer
solch gigantischen größe auch in der
lage die bildung von tropischen
wirbelstürmen zu beeinflussen zumindest
indirekt dazu heißt es in der studie
ich habe weiß dass diese partikel so
weit transportiert werden können ist
bedeutsam weil sie den strahlungs
transport um die erde und kohlenstoff
kreisläufe in den ozeanen beeinflussen
heißt also im klartext globale
klimamodelle müssen auf der basis dieser
neuen erkenntnisse grundlegend
überarbeitet werden das könnte auch das
bisherigem verständnis zum klimawandel
verändern klar ist dass die steigenden
temperaturen exakt mit den
menschengemachten klimagasen korrelieren
dh die temperaturen steigen synchron mit
dem vom menschen ausgestoßenen co2 und
methan allerdings können diese partikel
veränderungen hervorrufen die bisher
noch nicht bedacht worden im moment
sieht es ja so aus dass sich die effekte
wie zum beispiel der anstieg des
meeresspiegels dramatisch beschleunigen
vielleicht liegt es unter anderem an
diesen partikeln klimawandels fakt oder
fiktion draufklicken und raumzeit blog
beantwortet euch die frage also
anschauen abonnieren und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran